thank you hi uh thanks for coming so uh
our agenda today first is to uh discuss
what's the problem with vegetation
management and then we are going to dive
into the specifications of Lia data and
the challenges and steps in processing
laa and at the end we are going to
introduce some additional use cases and
the Pyon packages we used in our
solution so as some of you may have know
encoring vegetation is the primary cause
of power outages you can see from the
picture that uh overhead power Lins are
easily affected by the trees run it some
quick statistics uh in the US more than
97% of transmission and 70% of
distribution power Lins are
overhead and uh one of the major utility
companies reported that in 2020 77% of
their power
outages are tree
cost and a study conducted by University
of Connecticut showed that enhanced tree
triming uh reduces number of power aage
during stor by up to
48% therefore utility companies are
willing to spend billions of dollars
every year on Tre
and this highlights the critical need
for Effective vegetation Management on
uh the around the power
LS however the traditional method are
far from efficient so uh vegetation
inspection and spot checks are mostly
done manual and based on foot or AAL
patrols and uh there are overpaying and
complex breeding process due to a lack
of granular visibility to vegetation and
triming conditions and hardship on
reducing tree related outages due to
stat static and Long Tree treatment
Cycles cycle based treeing instead of uh
condition
based uh ignore the
challenges imposed by whether risks or
specific hazards related to uh tree
species and there are safety concerns
for our utility workers if the tree
aages are not
reduced we the current uh procedures
companies find it more and more
difficult to meet the regulation
regulatory requirements and customer
expectations they ought to find an
advanced vegetation management solution
not only to provide reliable services
but also to ensure safety and to cut the
cost on infrastruct infrastructure
repairing so there are four main
capabilities there are looking for first
is scalability to automatically assess
the state of vegetation across vast
areas in at scale across vast
areas and frequency to regularly predict
and prioritize areas where vegetation
May threaten power LS and cost
efficiency to achieve insights at scale
at the minimal investment and the time
to Insight will be significantly
shortened with our approach
and precision to invest in the right
data up front to ensure optimal
results okay let's see what is Lia data
Lia which stands for light detection and
ringing is a remote sensing method that
uses light in the form of a puled light
a laser to measure ranges to the
Earth in our context we are more
referring to Gaga mod lier it is
classified and including classes like
vegetation power lines poles and a
ground and buildings and so
on uh the data is in the form of uh of
Point cloud in the 3D space and each
point have its XY D and the class
information XY are the it's coordinates
and D represents its uh absolute height
comp to the C
Level but how do we get the relative
height of the points there here we we
have to use a data called uh digital TR
model or
DTM DTM is in the form of a 2d rer if we
overlay the lia on the
DTM so each pixel of the DTM with its
value represents the ground elevation of
the lighter points above it so by
subtracting the ground elevation from
the absolute height we will get the
relative
height and what are the differences
between gam mod Lia and linear lier so
and why gam Lia is
superior from the picture you see
basically the plane that flies G mod Lia
flies higher so it can capture a larger
areas and and it also capture from uh
multiple angles and at higher uh sample
rate so it can it was able it is able to
capture much more dense data and with
higher frequency and higher
Precision so uh based on the need of our
client uh gam mod Lia is a great fit for
our vegetation management
solution and before using Lia we rely on
satellite imagery as our source of data
for vegetation management but there are
two main uh issues with satellite first
is its resolution satellite only has
about 30 to 50
cm in resolution and but while laa is
very dense Point cloud in 3D space so
that's one and another is it does not
have the third dimension because it's in
2D so it l its height as as well as has
a class class information but instead it
has the color encoding so each pixel has
a rdb value which are red green and blue
three numbers so how do we use the three
numbers to do vegetation management
using using
satellite first we uh segment the Tre
polygons using a mix of image processing
clustering and modeling techniques and
using the trick canopy size we segment
it we C we assign a height to it and the
height are estimated because the tree
structure differs by the species and
also it is it is not uniform across the
whole tree reality right so uh and and
uh after that we calculate the distance
from the tree to the
while the by while we are using the GS
asset which provided by our client
but it uh but GSS said they usually come
with in accuracies you you can see here
from the picture red is the G lines and
the green are
the uh actual lines so from our analysis
about 10% of
the GS lens are not within 10 ft of the
actual line and 43% are not within three
ft of the actual
L and because they usually don't provide
height information in the ja as well we
have to estimate the height of the
line so uh as as client expect the
encroachment to be as precise as one
foot we struggle to meet this
expectation with the satellite approach
that's why we switch to Lia
eventually
in Lia we have the precise location and
height of the trees and WS so how do you
measure
encroachment thinking of the trees and
WS as a collection of points for each
point in this tree we calculate the
vertical and horizontal distance of it
to its nearby points showing on the
right on the left of the
picture and then we calculate a bunch of
3D
distances which with within certain
radius of the tree tree point and pick
the minimal as the minimal 3D distance
and showing on the
right then we agree the minimum 3D
distances a points to the wire to the
wire span so we know for each wire wild
spine was the minimal distance to the
encroaching
tree because vegetation information from
Lia are far more than what we need we
only Capt the vegetation Within the
right of way of the
wire for analysis the picture on the
right shows visually the vegitation
height the darker the green means the
taller the tree is and the picture on
the right visualizes the minimum 3D
distance of the vegetation to the
closest while the darker the red means
the closer the tree is to the closest
while in 3D at the end we we will have
to aggregate the minimal 3D distances to
the wild span which is what clients care
about the
most so do you guys have any questions
so
far yes I question about where do you
get the satellite or not the satellite
image the guer data from Yeah we
actually have a vendor who collects
those data oh
yes yes are you guys taking into account
in a model the droop that happens when
the power lines heat
up yes right yes we do
we we will talk about that yeah we'll
get there sorry no
no so okay let's hand to engine so thank
you Ken so right now we just wanted to
discuss about some challenges that we
face when we process this liar data
right and first challenge is like
missing or Spar wire points right so if
you can see from this picture this
picture is a representation of liar data
where the green points are the
vegetation the red points here are the
wire points
and from the left we see that there are
very few y points detected and in these
kind of scenarios we'll not be able to
calculate proper encroachment right and
whereas on the right hand side the Blue
Points actually represent the actual
wire points that are on the ground and
because of like missing or sparse points
we not able to detect a lot of
encroachment there on the tree and this
could be happening due to various
reasons so first thing could be the size
and coating of wire so if some of these
wires are so thin that the laser beam
hits the wire and does not bounce back
to the sensor sensor will not be able to
detect that there's some object there
and also sometimes when these wires are
coated with copper or material like four
strand steel they kind of reflect the
lar beams in different directions and it
causes uh lack of detection of points I
would say and sometimes there might be
vegetation that's like lying on top of
the wire so for example in in this
example itself if you have a wire that's
going underneath the tree if the lar
beam doesn't hit the like power line
points that are going underneath the
tree we would not be able to detect that
there's a power line underneath
there and sometimes the wire points
might not be classified properly so in
the collection step our vendor actually
collects the data and they also have a
classification step sometimes and uh due
to some uh like issues in classification
step sometimes what could happen is the
lighter points that are coming from The
Wire could be misclassified as coming
from something else and because of which
the points there might not be detected
and uh like I mentioned the problem the
this sparity in these points causes is
like lack of detection of actual
encroachment that's present on the
ground that's one Challenge and coming
to the Second Challenge uh the wire
configurations across the spans are not
same and what I mean by span is any
power line uh like points that are
present between two poles we'll be
calling them as spans from now on right
and uh the configuration of these power
lines between these two poles will not
be consistent across a grid of like
Electric
electrical across an electrical grid
let's say and these can be in like
multiple different configurations they
can be horizontally stacked which means
they are at a same elevation vertically
but they are spaced right next to each
other and they could be vertically
stacked as well in a similar way like
where they are like placed one on top of
the other and the image on the top kind
of shows the horizontal configuration
here right and combining both they could
be present in a hybrid configuration f
where there is horizontal wires and each
horizontal wire or each horizontal level
might have sorry there is vertical
levels and each vertical level might
have its own horizontal configuration
inside and this is one of the most
prevalent style of stacking that we tend
to
see and like I mentioned it's not
homogeneous across the power line grid
so it would be a challenge for us to
identify which span has which style of
stacking so we at IBM came up with a
solution for the sparity and stacking
problem and we call it Gap filling and
I'm going to walk you all through the
steps of Gap filling so the F first
thing is we need to identify the proper
pole location we need to identify where
the poles are and once we're done with
that we need to automatically find the
segments between the poles or like I
mentioned spans between the poles but
the major catch here is like if there
are 10 poles in a grid or a like power
line grid we would not know if we would
not know which pole is connected to
which other pole ahead of time because
like they could be connected in any
number of configurations right so our
algorithm automatically detects which
pole is connected to which other pole
and then we detect the segments between
these poles and the next step is where
we kind of identify which configuration
these power lines are present in either
horizontal vertical or hybrid and also
like uh after that we would need to get
the points that are present in each span
and identify which exact power line
these points are coming from in each
span because if let's say a span has
hybrid configuration and say we it has
two vertical levels and on the
bottommost level there's one single line
and on the topmost level there are three
horizontally stacked lines we have to go
to the segment and our Auto automatic
algorithm kind of identifies which power
line exactly each of these points are
coming from and then we use that
information to kind of
interpolate and uh fill the gaps in the
power lines and this is where we account
for the SAG in the power lines as well
so like he mentioned during summer times
or during different weather conditions
the power lines could be sagging very
differently because of the material of
the power lines and this algorithm also
accounts for
that and after all this is done we
perform automated quality checks uh due
to which uh all the lines that are fit
according to the Norms or according to
what they should actually look like will
be retained and every other line that's
fit wrongly or falsely will be removed
and uh next major challenge here is so
initially we calculate encroachment to
all the lines present in a span but
sometimes the client does not really
care about encroachment from like let's
say neutral wire or service wire or
communication lines so let me quickly
touch upon what these lines are so the
primary and secondary lines are the
lines that carry electricity and so is
the service wire but primary primary
lines carry like Electric with a higher
voltage and secondary with slightly
lesser voltage and communication lines
are like the telephone lines usually
that are present on the same
pole and service wires are the wires
that carry electricity to the
households and client usually uh mostly
asks for
encroachment uh to primary and secondary
wires and they don't really care that
much about neutral and communication
because they don't carry any electricity
and also if primary and secondary wires
uh like uh have encroachment near them
there there could be a chance that these
trees that are encroaching on them can
catch fire and that could cause a fire
hazard so that's another reason as to
why we care more about the primary and
secondary wires and the challenge here
is uh we have to identify what each of
these wires are and what like what style
they are because just from lar we will
not be able to know which wires carry
charge and which wires do not so we have
devised our own in-house algorithm to
kind of classify these wires as to like
communication
electric and uh we tend to give
encroachment based on the client
requirements if they want it for all of
them we give it for all of them if they
want it only for electric clients we
give it only for electric
clients and
uh so misclassification is a challenge
that I touched upon previously and uh
like I mentioned certain time uh
sometimes like if there are electric
lines and if we see that there are
vegetation points so from this picture
right the green points are the points uh
that are coming from vegetation and
yellow ones are the ones that are coming
from electric lines or power lines and
the pink is the pole points and
sometimes like we can see in this
picture there could be a case where some
of the electric wires could be
misclassified as vegetation and because
of this if we directly go with this data
we would give wrong encroachment values
because uh this looks like it's there's
a serious encroachment in here and
there's a tree between the power lines
but that's not actually true and this uh
this happens sometimes and we have our
own like inhouse algorithm that kind of
detects this and a small part of the
algorithm is to kind of identify if
there are like small clusters of these
vegetation points between power lines or
inside power lines and if there are any
vegetation that these vegetation around
these like cluster that these points
could be coming from and if that's not
the case we use certain other steps that
I cannot disclose then we kind of remove
those points from here and we do not
calculate encroachment from them
[Music]
so I just wanted to show you a quick
demo here uh about how like what the Gap
filling looks like and in the interest
of time I'm only going to be showing
three
segments or three spans let's
say so this tool is called Cloud compare
and it helps us visualize lar data and
the white points we are seeing here are
the pole points if I zoom in
uh so this we what we're seeing here is
a
segment and the blue points are the
power line points and we can see that
they very sparse
here and the white points here are the
like poles bit like that are having
these power line points and as we can
see right there are two stack there's
two wires here one stacked on top of the
other so it is the vertical stacking
configuration and let's see what uh our
Gap filling algorithm did here so it
finds the like missing wire points and
it kind of fills them and the
configuration is
retained and let me jump to another
segment so this is also a vertical
stacking configuration
example
right and this is what the field line
looks
like and we have seen enough of vertical
stacking so let's take a look at hybrid
stacking now which is one of the more
challenging ones so can anyone guess how
many vertical lines there are
here so this is the side
view yeah so there is there's two wires
here and on the topmost wire can you
tell me how many wires there are
horizontally three yeah exactly three so
let me show you what our Gap filling
algorithm does
here it fills them perfectly so we have
three on top one at the
bottom
is there any confusion you have any
questions why only one at the bottom
there was only one at the bottom from
the so that configuration is also
possible yeah yeah so like hybrid
stacking could have multiple styles of
configuration inside itself so it
doesn't have always have to be
horizontal stacking everywhere so there
could uh like like it's shown here there
could be one vertical line at the bottom
on the top most vertical section they
can have
three so I can yeah so let me rotate
this for you so so this three on top and
one at the
bottom and uh so that's it from
challenges so let me give control back
to my colleague kin thanks
engine also uh feel free to ask if you
guys have any questions yes do yes
please so like say you plot um oh the
algorithm fills in like the lines how do
you verify that it actually did it
correctly we have a couple of like I
discussed before we have certain steps
where we do quality checks based on uh
what we know about power lines and what
we know about power line structure and
stuff like that I can't diverge too much
information there but we do have a
quality assessment St yeah like actual
images from like the place no it's it's
entirely automated so we don't have to
do anything manually so the quality
assessment also happens automatically
and uh like bad lines are removed
sometimes if we want to go back and
check we can check how it look what it
looks like
usually thanks sometimes you have power
lines with spacers where're central line
to hold it metal pieces are you guys
able to handle that with your models yes
okay so as long as U as long as we can
see the power line points in lar we're
able to handle them that's awesome y
thank you yes please the vegetation
misclassification you're using proximity
to like the rest of it to say it's Mis
classified I'm just wondering like how
you know for sure it's misclassified
like you need to know how trees look um
with the lar model like you know could
you have a little offshoot that actually
is there and you think it's
misclassified yes uh the example I
showed with the proximity uh to other
vegetation points is just an example
there uh there's a more complicated
algorithm that just one of the steps
that I wanted to point out and uh yeah
we do have we do take into account uh
like the issues that you're talking
about it could actually be a vegetation
where there's an offshoot but those kind
of scenar are already handled so we I
can't like disclose too much here but
yeah I get your
question yes yes please you go first do
you use deep learning or something for
the modeling we use machine learning we
don't use deep learning as such yeah
basally machine
learning model or
something uh yeah I so it is a it is a
machine learning model that's that's as
far as I can say I believe sorry yeah
anyone else no you're good okay thank
you okay so let's uh dive into the steps
on processing
ler yes okay uh the first obviously is
to ingest data which is L and DTM L is
the file format for Lia it is a classifi
it is classified and including classes
like vegetation poles structures and WS
and DTM as we discussed earlier is the
ground elevation of the
ligher and then we extract the
vegetation while and pole which we are
interested from the lia data and then
because the provided Lia files are very
a small piece as cover only small pieces
of area so we have to aggor them to the
to a larger area for easy processing and
then we detect and filling sparse wild
data then uh we do some pre-processing
on the w
and to extract only energized lines and
filter out lines that neutral and uh
communication
lines and then we uh after that we
computed the various distance of
vegetation to the wire and then we do
some generating some kpis and then
assign them to the C JS
data so some kpi we mainly interested in
uh 2D distance and 3D distance also the
encroachment encroachment value which is
the amount of encroachment in some
ranges of the 3D distance and at the end
we will assign a ladder score to the
Wild span based on the 3D distances for
example D it means uh three the 3D
distance is within 0 to 3 ft and which
which means it uh is in critical
condition and need to be Tri the
vegetation need to be trimmed
immediately and c means the next
critical next next critical stage and
which need to be watched
closely and uh so on so
forth another challenge uh in this step
is how to
scale very
big amount a large amount of lighter
data for a mediumsized client there may
we end up with more than 10,000 files in
our data in our data storage maybe like
more than like terabytes of data so how
do we scale first we uh we create this
kubernetes cluster which is able to
round the jobs in parallel and they can
have multiple nodes and as many nodes as
we requested actually and then using
because our our steps are like mainly
Gap building distance calculation kpr
configuration C generation right we uh
create darker images for each of them
because uh some of them may and drawn
them in uh
containers some of them may consume more
uh memory and CPU than the others so we
have to do it like this and we used a
workflow tool to orchestrate the
workflow of
the
containers and so uh once the systems
are set
up we just need to change the
uh demo file of each workflow pipeline
so that
um before each run so it will run
automatically and
perfectly
next uh we will discuss some uh
additional use cases of lither data and
our vegetation management first is how
to is to analyze the link of the PO
to this is to assist utility with uh
replacing their leaning pose before it
actually FS or causing any issues right
and then to identify the distance of
power to the water ground and objects
they say to ensure safety and to meet uh
regulations and to uh analyze the power
L stack also to ensure safety and
prevent
outages another one is
to to predict the future growth without
recollecting L this way we new data can
be collected every two or three years
without instead of every year therefore
the cost to acquir L can be
significantly
reduced this is example of
polling we clustered the the pole you uh
from the lia data and we uh calculate
the polling based on the structure of
the pole and the link are represented in
both magnitude and
Direction same as Gap fing there are all
kinds of issues but we are not going to
dive into this
here and some essential packages we have
used we used the uh last pie for working
with Lia Point cloud data and uh Ral ra
real X array to work with rest
images geopandas shapely to work with
Vector data and we used the GS
operations from forest and Vector for
from the gll library and the GS
operations for Point cloud from the P
ped
Library some scientific Computing
methods like finding the nearest
Neighbors From the s pi and some machine
learning techniques like the clustering
method and cod fitting method from the
psychic learn
package so this concludes our
presentation today thank you guys for
your time and
[Applause]
attention